ATR indicator can be used to find massive breakouts like right here.
But most traders haven't learned how to use it correctly.
So in this video, you will learn all the most important things
you need to learn about the ATR indicator.
You will learn how to use it to trade breakouts, but many other things as well.
Like how do I use the ATR to set my profit target and stop loss.
And I will even show you some special settings you can use
to potentially improve the indicator even further
but right so let's begin here by answering the critical question what is the ATR indicator
well ATR stands for average true range and this right here is an indicator a very famous one
created by Jay Wells Wilder, and it's used to measure volatility.
Volatility is a very important concept, and if you want to learn more about it,
I do have a video about that, so I will make sure to link that video
up in the corner in the eye.
But in simple terms, volatility basically measures how much
an asset like a stock or cryptocurrency moves around its moving average.
所以你能看,它显示了 how much的 asset typically moves
或是在一切期間的距離
而在一切中的ATR,它 works across stocks, forex, crypto
如果你投入 gold或其他人,它基本上 works across all markets
所以現在,如何做ATR?
如果你想用ATR effectively,
it's in my opinion important to understand at least a little bit of how the ATR works.
It's not super important to learn the math but just to have a basic understanding.
So the ATR uses something called true range and it's a bit complicated because this is basically
the largest of either the high minus low or absolute value of high minus previous close
或是最高的效率
在我的 opinion
解釋 exactly what this means
是不太重要
但最重要的是
是在ATR工作
以測量的一種
通常的一種量
然后它 takes
一种平均的一種量
这种量
这是我们的
这个是我们的ATR
and the standard setting is to use 14 period.
But as I mentioned, later on in this video,
I will show you guys some special settings
that can potentially improve your ATR even more.
And on trading platforms like TradingView,
if you have been following our channel for a while,
you know that I really like TradingView.
The ATR is often just shown as a simple line
below the price charts.
但是现在,为什么我们用了ATR?
我说,在它的预算是在它的预算是一种根据的指数
或者是在其中的指数,或者是在其中的调略
或者是调略的市场
我们可以用了ATR为很多不同的事情
例如,例如,词试的变化
我们会用了看一看ATR的变化
to set smarter, both stop losses and also profit targets.
And there are many other use cases as well, like, you know, filter trades based on volatility conditions.
So you might, for example, only trade in certain environments where the ATR is at a certain range,
because perhaps your trading strategy works in a certain range.
ATR是在一段階段的限制
可能你的投資方法 works
在高-volatility environments
而不是低-volatility,等等
ATR simply gives us有a realistic expectation for how much an asset might move in the near termall right so next I do want to talk about some you know common ATR settings and you know how
you can potentially improve them but I do think I will save this for later on in this video
when we you know are in trading view because that's much easier so now let's actually jump
to the next slide and take a look at some of the most popular and best ATR based trading strategies.
So the first one I want to talk about is the breakout strategy and this one can be very useful.
This one is usually you know either waiting for a low ATR period or waiting for the ATR to break a key level.
所以你能用例如,譬如,
当价值运动,当价值运动,
当价值运动的特别是1.5或2X.
如果这些人会很难,
不怕,我会将你会很快速的事情。
这些可以很高兴,例如,新增值。
第四个选择,我会说的是,
用ATR减少和取消货。
This is a pretty similar trading strategy where you use multiples of ATR to get your stop loss and profit target levels.
You can also use a trailing stop loss with ATR, which is basically when the stop loss is sort of following your trade.
And you can use 1x or 2x ATR as realistic targets, but it will depend a little bit on what time frame and so on you're using.
and now guys I do have as you can see I do have some more strategies as well but in this video we
don't have time to go through them all so I think I will save the rest of the strategies for our
YouTube community and our YouTube channel members if you didn't didn't know we do have an amazing
community right here on YouTube where I share extra material such as full presentations like
这个一条,我还分享了一些新的视频,
你也有什么新的视频,
很多更多东西。
所以,如果你想要这个全面的视频
和同时支持你的视频,
请记得加入这个视频
按下来的视频,
但现在我们其实进入了一个视频,
因为现在我现在要与大家
与大家的ATR划算是一步的,
首先,现在我们现在看了
Bitcoin on the daily timeframe
but this as I talked about earlier
you can use the ATR on pretty much all timeframes
and pretty much all assets
so if you trade stocks or Forex
don't worry you can do that as well
and here on this particular example
this is a very great example in my opinion
because you can see here that Bitcoin
saw a very significant resistance here
you can see we got reacted multiple multiple times
and then eventually we saw this massive, massive breakout.
But the question now is,
how could we have used the ATR indicator
to actually spot this breakout
and also help us to find our profit target
and stop-loss levels?
Well, to understand this,
we first of course need to open up the ATR indicator.
So to do this, we go up here to the indicators tab
and then you can simply search for ATR
and it should come up right here.
You can see TradingView has a built-in
average true range indicator
and we also have tons of different slight variations
of the ATR created by the community.
But for this video, I do think I will stick here
with the normal average true range.
So let's open this one up.
And also, by the way, guys,
if you for some reason haven't gotten started
我会有特别的特别提供的特别提供
我会有特别提供的特别提供你会会有15do think the ATR indicator is available for the free version
but I'm pretty sure some of these indicators are not available on all
TradingView versions
So if you want to get the full experience with TradingView Premium
you can definitely consider using that link
but now first of all i just want to change some settings real quick for the ATR so i go to the
settings tab and i just want to make the line a bit thicker here so you can clearly see but first
of all when it comes to breakouts what i'm looking out for is something called momentum candles and
one way to identify momentum candles in my opinion is that the candle should be at least
兩次,或是三次,
甚至大小,
像是前提前的
但我說這個,
這就是一個很可憐的問題
因為你可能問
你問,你問,
你問,
然後,
這個,
是,
那是,
這個,
80R,
因為,
instead,
你問,
那,
在,
我們,
we need the price to trade twice or two times as much as the ATR.
So what do I mean here?
So if we take a look at the candle that broke the very important resistance
we talked about earlier, what you can do here is that you can come down,
you can hover your mouse over the ATR,
and you can see that the average true range for this candle,
or in other words the period of 14 candle that it uses to calculate was around 2576.
So in order to have two times the ATR we need the candle to be you know more than $5,000.
And let's actually take a look at how much was this candle.
while we hover over the candle and you can see up in the middle
that this candle was around 6,000 US dollar.
The range of the candle was around 6,000 US dollar.
I can show this with this price range tool.
You can see from there to there around 6,000 US dollar,
meaning that we have more than twice the ATR.
and this right here can help us confirm the breakout.
But of course, guys, you don't want to only rely on the ATR.
On this chart right here, we're actually already using market structure.
This key level right here is a clear example of important market structure.
And if you want to learn more about market structure,
I do have a full course about that,
and I will make sure to link that course somewhere up in the corner in the eye.
You also want to use price action.
Price action and market structure is basically the foundation of,
at least in my opinion, pretty much all technical analysis.
So I do have a full price action trading course as well,
and I will make sure to link it up in the corner in the eye.
I highly recommend to check out both of these courses eventually.
But, you know, do take your own time.
you don't have to go through them right away but now you know that you can use a multiple of the
ATR to find these key breakouts but how can we use it for our stop loss and profit target well
let's use our long position let's say that we identify this breakout we use the ATR maybe we
used another indicator like volume as well now you might wonder how can we use the ATR to set
我們可以重新用數量的數量
很多時候,你不需要用2x
你可能需要用1.5
但你也可以用2x所以,2x的數量 5000 so around here so this could have been a stop loss and using a 2 to 1 risk to reward ratio your your risk to reward would have
looked something like this but right so now let's switch the attention a bit here and take a look at
how we can change the settings of the ATR
to potentially improve it even further.
Because so far in the video,
everything we have done here with the breakout training strategy
has actually been with the standard average true range settings.
But now let's actually go down and change the settings here.
And to do this, we go down here to where it says ATR
and you press on the cogwheel right here.
then you want to head to the inputs tab
and as you can see here the standard setting for the ATR is 14 for the length
and the smoothing is the RMA
what does this mean?
well the length is how many periods
or in other words how many candles the ATR uses for its calculation
and the RMA here is the special moving average
that is commonly used for the ATR.
And the standard ATR settings is, in my opinion,
pretty solid for most situations.
However, there are a few markets and situations
where we can consider changing the settings.
For example, if you are a day trader or even a scalper,
so you might trade on the 5-minute, 15-minute,
or even 1-minute time frame,
then you might actually want to decrease the length of the ATR.
Some of the recommended settings here is either 10.
This will actually already give you quite a few,
you know, the signals will already be much faster.
But some traders change it all the way down to 7.
So 7 will give you very fast signals.
But yet another thing you can actually do,
this is a bit more uncommon,
but you can change from the RMA to an EMA.
An EMA is an exponential moving average
so it gives much more weight to the previous movements.
And you can see that by changing here to EMA,
take a close look at the ATR indicator,
you can see that it changes a lot.
From RMA to EMA,
you can see that the EMA goes up and down much more quickly
and that is because it gives more weight
to recent price movements.
So 7 EMA gives extremely fast signals, but at the same time it might give more false signals as well.
So do be a bit careful if you go with this setting.
However, if you are more on the swing trading or investing side, you might want to consider much more conservative settings.
so let's change back here to rma and let's actually instead of going back to 14 let's change it up
all the way to 20 you can see that when we change it to 20 you will get a much smoother atr and
this can actually be useful as i said if you are a much longer term trader and are looking for
perhaps catching you know whole trends or at least at least larger movements you can even go
非常 extreme and change the setting of like for example 50 and you will get a super a super smooth
ATR but yeah guys as I said earlier this is just you know scratching the surface when it comes to
the ATR it's a very powerful indicator and we can dive a lot deeper but this video is getting a bit
too long here I'm sorry if it got a little bit rambling but yeah guys if you want to dive even
更深入的ATR
我會把這個影片放在一起
給我們的YouTube頻道
我會喜歡看到你們在一起
但現在,大家看好
以為使用的ATR更加強
我非常推薦你進入的
市場的建築
所以當你時間到時,請看這個影片
接下來